oh tell you what i meant this is
annoying really because uh i'm in the
worst place possible for it but america
are probably better big big asses
latino women you like big ass latino
women yeah yeah yeah like huge thick
women you like big thick ones i know i
like this yeah yeah what do you mean do
you like this guy
i want something like that other men go
don't know about that like i want that
really yeah i want a challenge why is
that i don't know i just think with a
normal sized woman it's quite easy for
me to sort of do what i want oh but so
you want a girl to fight back not a
fight
you're speaking
there's no hands raised yeah you know
what i'm saying i just mean a wrestle
a little bit of a challenge you know
what i mean you've got a you got a
there's actually the same both times
yeah yeah
i want you to know that you said the
same thing twice
a few inches of cheeks just to make it
to the hole there you go i see i don't
want to feel like it's just why are you
you got a piece on you is that no i'm
not suggesting that yeah i mean if
people want to surmise that that's up to
them
what do you have i think it's quite
average if i'm honest it's average but
average on you because that's still
probably that's the thing right you've
made a [ __ ] good point there
this is the thing right it's like if you
have a huge house with a big garage and
then you have a normal sized car it
looks small that looks weird right
so like if if you don't have a range
rover yeah people are like wow yeah
right so that's all i'm going to say
yeah my balls have been growing lately i
might have some issue there what
happened with that i don't know about
what balls keep growing but you feel
that as well you may say my dick was
shrinking i swear to god i thought my
dick was getting smaller and i almost
like googled it and i was like your
dicks get smaller like i thought there
was like a pill i was taking what is the
answer to that googlebot say again what
is the answer to that i almost did
because i didn't want to do it i didn't
want to know the answer but i think my
balls are getting bigger and i think
that's the thing you're talking about
you're a big guy even if you have a
regular sized dick it's going to look
small that's good that's it that's why
women think these short skinny dudes
have huge dicks they just shortened the
bank yeah the [ __ ] is holy [ __ ] that's a
great point yeah now what about a big
one of you
say again i've been stitched up in life
you got circumstances
but like all of these you have the hood
you have everything you got the you guys
nobody touched up my dick when i was
born or since then yeah is that weird
get out of here you might connect there
you go
is it
wait is that got a sensitive penis
unlike you uh circumcised i'm sensitive
to it
it's that moment when it first goes in
man yeah you have that too
what do you think is your dick's been
bashing around on stuff unprotected yes
mine's bulletproof you really think
absolutely
when you pull it back to pee are you
like nutting at the urinal sometimes
it just feels so only there's you're
just next to me if i look over then
maybe
what's the quickest you can manage to
not
that i can come yeah man or woman
either okay um
woman if you're on your own what about
if you're on your own oh dude i've come
before i'm fully hard i honestly look
that's a good one right i know
[Laughter]
that's how fast bro that's how fast i
can get it out quick
yeah i like those ones when you're not
fully hard yeah why do you like them
don't know efficiency you like your
efficiency yeah yeah it's also like a
little bit lazy as well i guess yeah i
feel like a psychopath yeah yeah when i
when i can nut not fully hard i'm like
no this isn't the moment me dude
you know you have nerve endings in your
foreskin that the doctor got rid of and
threw in the garbage why do people do
that why do people think you threw it in
the garbage dude well wait did he didn't
obviously we're [ __ ] native americans
yeah wait what did you watch that
documentary on netflix
you made a macaroni out of this dude
okay
on netflix where the doctor was like
yeah
i'm i'm taking semen from these people
and it was just the doctors come the
whole time and he impregnated all those
[ __ ] women wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait what what
is this so you know women who are going
through uh issues with fertility and
then he gave him what to do we all went
to this doctor who was the best in the
business yeah yeah meanwhile he was
going into his office not in one out
putting it in and he was like yep got
this sample from one of our guys and he
was telling them that can i just play
devil's outfit [ __ ] sick he's related
[Music]
they're going to have doctor sperm yes
yeah a doctor that thinks taking a lot
of women's sperm so that's good every
man likes the woman
what do you think about dr sperm is so
good
i think it's better you want an indian
guy's sperm really
i don't know about it i don't know he
was an indian what was he just caucasian
dude but he was ugly as well so a lot of
his kids were ugly but he must have been
smart as [ __ ] to be a white
doctor you know
all over everyone's eyes like he
impregnated a city yeah there was over
50 kids and they were finding each other
through like ancestry
and they were like [ __ ] they could
have been shocking each other or
anything do you call it pulling the wool
over your eye when you when you put the
thing back
is that yeah
gotcha okay now this guy while i think
he's bad maybe he justified it by going
listen i'm gonna put this high iq [ __ ] in
these women who are having difficulty
getting pregnant okay so that i think
there was an element of uh white
supremacy in there as well talk to me uh
because towards the end it was like he
was a very religious man he was like uh
shock
which religion uh he was christian
catholic uh i think so and he was a
protestant yeah
makes the most sense catholic huh yeah
catholic huh point of that this
catholic don't point that at me in
england dude his hair is unbelievable by
the way yeah
dude you gotta see it when it's pulled
back
it
[Music]
those lovely curly locks we love it
scottish
[Laughter]
do you think that's possible do you
believe in the loch ness monster he had
sex
yeah a few of them uh did you hear about
uh that they say that that could have
been a real thing yes i saw this so
there's a new article come out basically
as i could they say it was an old
dinosaur that likely just died yeah as
well i mean
me and my people believe in it yeah your
people me and my people believe i mean i
went to it why is that so hard to
believe sons of scotland yeah
yeah
clan cameron dude we were actually the
before we were the sheep um thieves and
the queen's guard
we were the keepers of the lock
oh really you were the queen's guard you
cuck
you [ __ ] this guy thinks because he's
indian they got their independence by
not eating that he's some [ __ ] brave
guy that's right he didn't fight for
[ __ ]
you've seen you without food for six
hours you're such a [ __ ]
you're such a [ __ ]
can i be honest with you
i need to eat something
[Laughter]
dude what they did is so much easier
than just shooting people yeah not 80
that is the ultimate bravery especially
as a man [ __ ] losing your mind dude
dude that is crazy women are good
looking oh yeah there you go oh you
don't really feel that way oh really i
do wait really yeah yeah oh [ __ ] did you
get in trouble or something you have to
say some of them are like
some of them some of them are don't you
think the guys are better looking no
let's go now you know you're just saying
it now you guys just saying it bollywood
actresses are hot come on dude come on
there's no he's never seen that no you
gotta you gotta show them your cousin so
this you gotta show him because he's
i went to his wedding with my wife i
would have left my wife
at his wedding for just show the picture
but make sure you show the one with the
eyes
with the eyes oh my god the eyes are
unbelievable you've used this photograph
plenty of times he's here right
um he is here can we get him no he's
left today he loves buying it and then
can we tie him up and use his holes geez
what payback dude it's payback dude
why are you showing them like they don't
know what he looks like even find the
best picture why don't we show true
jordan picture bro because i want to
find the best picture of everything i
mean
oh yeah that's a handsome balloon dude
it's the it's the it's the stair oh yeah
he also doesn't look that honestly
that's not even that's the most
attractive part yeah
wow this is not even the this is not
honestly this is not even the best
looking picture you don't even get to
see how blue the eyes that's what i'm
saying find a good picture okay i'm
gonna find a good picture but i mean
he's horrible at taking pictures or
maybe i was just seduced by something
else
because
now you're flipping on him that's [ __ ]
up
i mean
we should just take a break right now
and let you finish let me just get this
out of the system here we go i mean look
yeah
i mean yeah he got it
right now he's like
how did we get into this big blue
latinas yeah i think so yeah yeah yeah
you gotta go to the states yeah yeah
they don't have them in this country
unfortunately yo where do you go for ass
here in europe that's not it just
doesn't expand apparently
what if like the migrant crisis in the
us that everyone talks about all these
conservatives blah blah blah oh they're
busted migrants whatever whatever we put
them on a plane yeah bring them to
england
and then they can get into the the
population and then make big buddhism
english mark you know this for a fact
that mexican women are not known for
their asses but they're not no where the
latinos come from with the asses what no
no latinas
and mexican women with asses are very
different the asses that the latinas
have that you're probably thinking about
this is puerto rico dominican republic
venezuela brazil
colombia how do we get a migrant crisis
with them we got to do that
yeah that yeah we need that i mean they
would need more like boats and that kind
of stuff to get here yeah but but
mexican women are not known for their
their should it be a step up for you
know england maybe it really would be